what we're going to do in this video is
talk about proteins and some of you all
might already be familiar with them at
least in some context if you look at any
type of packaging on food you'll
oftentimes see a label that has protein
listed in a certain number of grams per
serving and some of you who might be
athletically inclined might associate it
with things that help you build muscle
and none of that is incorrect but as
we'll see in this video and in many
future videos proteins are involved in
almost every single biological process
in every single living organism
and if we ask ourselves what are they
well they're biomolecules they're
molecules found in biological systems
and they're large biomolecules we could
call them macro molecules
molecules which is just referring to
they're made up of many many many many
many atoms
these right here are pictures two
different views of the chaperonin
protein and this is the chaperonin
protein is roughly eight hundred
thousand times the mass of a hydrogen
atom so it's going to contain tens of
thousands of atoms which would very much
make it a macro molecule now one thing
to be careful of
even though these are very very large on
a molecular scale even the largest
protein we know of titan is about one
micrometer in length and that's much
larger than this saproni here and a
micrometer is one thousandth of a
millimeter so even the largest proteins
are microscopic
now another way to think about proteins
is what they are made up of
so some proteins are made up of a single
chain of something called amino acids
and things like chaperonin are made up
of multiple chains of amino acids so in
a little bit i'll show you some
particular amino acids but for now just
think of them as the building blocks of
proteins so let's say that's an amino
acid and then it will bond to another
amino acid it's not just one type of
amino acid and they can form these
really
really really long chains and so let me
be very clear
this is an amino
acid and it's called that because it
contains an amine group which you don't
have to worry about for now
and they are the monomers that form the
polymers of what's known as polypeptide
chains so these are
monomers
you build you connect them together
and and you can keep going you can have
hundreds or even thousands of these and
so this whole thing right over here you
can consider to be a
polymer
and a chain of amino acids the polymer
of amino acids is known as a polypeptide
polypeptide
and sometimes a polypeptide chain is a
protein but sometimes a protein can be
made up of multiple polypeptide chains
put together and what happens is after
these amino acids connect or bond to
each other they're they they bend and
they form the shape of these proteins so
you can imagine the chaperonin protein
right over here it has these chains of
amino acids that bend have a
conformation that form the shape and
that's really what gives proteins their
power and as i mentioned proteins are
involved in almost every single
biological function they play a
structural
structural
role they play a mechanical role when
your muscles contract you have actin and
myosin proteins interacting with each
other so that your muscle contracts they
can act as enzymes which we will talk
about in a lot more depth in future
videos enzymes help catalyze reactions
they help biological biochemical
reactions happen in biological systems
they can be involved with the immune
system they could be involved with
signaling they can send signals from one
part of the body to another or they can
be receptors on cells that receive
signals so proteins are incredibly
incredibly important
now with that out of the way let's dig a
little bit deeper into the building
blocks of proteins the monomers that
build up the polymers that are
polypeptides which could be proteins or
which could be used to build up proteins
so what we see on the left here is the
typical structure of an amino acid
notice you see some oxygens you see some
hydrogen some carbons and a nitrogen and
then bonded to this carbon right over
here you see this r and you say what
element is that well this is not an
element this is referring this is kind
of a placeholder for a side chain which
differentiates the common amino acids
and you see some of the common amino
acids in this diagram right over here
and you can see what the r would be for
this arginine right over here that r
group would be this part and you don't
have to understand the
biochemistry of it in too much detail
but you can see that they all have this
top part in common but then they all
have a different r group
right over here and it's different
sequences of these amino acids that give
us the diversity of all of the proteins
that we have in biological systems and
all of the various shapes and it really
really really really is amazing i mean
just going back to this picture of
chaperonin which is involved with
helping other proteins get their shape
their it's chaperones the protein
folding process so to speak just think
about the complexity this looks like a
complex machine but it forms naturally
in biological systems and as we explore
more and more biology we keep seeing
these fascinating proteins that look
like these incredible systems that
really boggle the imagination